la salida de las tropas francesas de
malí continúa este martes el estado
mayor francés confirmó la restitución de
la base de gos y situada a 100
kilómetros al oeste de gau es la cuarta
base que regresa al control de las
fuerzas malienses después de tessalit
tombuctú y kidal en el norte del país en
france 24 el portavoz del estado mayor
francés anunció la retirada total del
ejército francés de malí que tendrá
lugar de aquí hasta el fin del verano el
hueco si marca la primera etapa
importante de retiro de marios nos queda
transferir a mena acá y después a cabo
de aquí hacia el final de verano si al
final del verano ya no habrá soldados
franceses estacionados en mal
estacionamiento bamako el pasado 19 de
febrero una multitud estalló de alegría
después de un anuncio de la junta en el
poder el día anterior los militares
pidieron afronte a retirar del país a
sus soldados de la fuerza abarcan
inmediatamente el enésimo episodio de
tensión entre parís y bamako desde el
golpe de estado de mayo de 2021 la junta
maliense le reprocha a la fuerza de ser
ineficiente en la lucha contra el
terrorismo
parís por su parte se niega a trabajar
en el mismo suelo que el grupo de
mercenarios rusos wagner llamado como el
esfuerzo por la junta maliense desde
bruselas bien compañeros sus socios en
la guerra en manuel ma q haya tomado
nota de la demanda maliense y anunciado
la salida de las tropas francesas de
malí examen ahora las fuerzas marinas
van a tener que llevar sus operaciones
solas ya que esta decisión tomada por el
presidente de la república resulta
directamente de las posiciones que
tomaron las autoridades malienses
entonces ahora es su problema manejar el
combate contra los grupos armados
terroristas este lunes el ejército
maliense recibió un nuevo cargamento de
equipos rusos incluyendo dos
helicópteros de combate y gradas